what are the steps in the comic heroes
Journey yeah there are seven steps I I
recently read a paper that that
referenced the comic heroes journey and
they talked about how I shoehorned the
12 steps of the hero's journey into
seven into seven sips of the comic
hero's journey and I did that you know
just because you know safe space make it
a little make it a little bit more
economical
um basically the cover of your book so
the hero's journey we have the normal
World which we talked about and WTF
that's the comic premise and then you
have reaction
um in reaction you have your character
in this transformed state or this
transformed uh circumstance but they
don't want to be there uh it's it's
Dorothy wanting to go home it's uh
Phil Connors and Groundhog Day trying to
figure out how do I get out of this so
so there's first denial and then the
reaction is
okay this is happening how how do I not
make it happen how do I go back how do I
fix this
um and and in some cases it's unfixable
like uh in big he goes to sleep as a 13
year old boy he wakes up he's a 30 year
old man but it doesn't need to be an
impossible it could be improbable in
enough said uh film with Julia Louis
Dreyfus in the late great James
Gandolfini Julia Louis-Dreyfus is a is a
massage therapist and she finds out that
her new boyfriend is the ex-husband of
her new best friend both of you know who
she now is is giving massages to so when
she gives massages to her new best
friend
who tells terrible things about her
ex-husband she then reacts to it when
she's on a date with James Gandolfini
who's the ex-husband and so as she's
trying to figure out what to do about it
she's carrying on uh just a mild
deception she's simply not telling
either one about the other but but in
the beginning she's
trying to
make make believe like this is not an
impossible situation to be in and of
course uh in that movie when it blows up
it destroys her relationship uh which is
what happens
in a movie at uh the oldest lost moment
but you have the reaction then you have
connections in connections your
characters are forming a nucleus around
themselves a a family uh friends that
they hadn't had before and what you have
in that section is things are starting
to slow down you have characters who are
who up till then had not even had a
conversation with each other and now
they're kind of opening up to each other
in in some comedies the opening up is uh
a little bit ridiculous
um but in in many comedies it's where
the characters for the first time
are relating to two other characters uh
in a way that they hadn't before
um one of the things I want to talk
about in terms of these seven steps is
they don't have to happen all in the
same order they don't have to happen all
at the same page you know this page this
has to happen because they all happen in
different ways in
40 Year Old Virgin
the connections start pretty soon after
uh after the uh lie after the truth
about his being a virgin comes out uh he
goes to work they make fun of him he
runs away and Paul Rudd because Paul
Rudd is a nice guy he's the guy who's
all emo and he's still yearning after
his girlfriend he runs after him and he
chases him down he doesn't have to if
Paul Rudd doesn't chase him down there's
no movie that's the end of the movie
that you know Steve Carell has has
um
has has you know quit but he chases them
down and they go and they have a cup of
coffee together and it's the first time
that they're talking to each other and
Steve Carell even says you know this is
the first time we've had a conversation
of more than more than you know two
minutes and connections is where your
character who up till that point had
been
a loner or either through choice or or
through their own circumstances and they
begin to gather a group around
themselves a group that can become their
friends I mean in Bridesmaids she
literally has a group of Bridesmaids
that first she's very antagonistic to or
or she uh she give them all food
poisoning because she's trying too hard
but at the end they they have all bonded
so that's what happens in connections
and in connections you slow the pace
down so that people can have real
conversations
um one of the things that Monty Python
discovered
when they did their first movie uh and
Now for Something Completely Different
which was a compilation of sketches that
they had done on TV
and they did this movie for the American
Market because at that time Monty Python
was still not being shown in America and
they did a test screening
and they found out in the test screening
it went great for the first 45 minutes
people were laughing hysterically and
then they just stopped
for the next 45 minutes and they the
pythons kind of looked at each other and
thought well maybe we have it we have
this in the wrong order so they
re-shuffled some of the sketches and
they did another screening
and again for the first 45 minutes
people were peeing in their pants and
then it stopped because you just cannot
make an audience laugh for 90 minutes
non-stop without giving them something
to chew on
without giving them some protein
and that's why for their next two movies
well especially especially a Life of
Brian
they gave you characters you could care
about
and characters who are going through a
trauma and trying to find their way out
of it
so even though the pythons were very
sketch based and even though Life of
Brian is still a series of sketches it
was still telling a story about a guy
that you identified with and empathize
with so that's why it's so important at
some point in your movie to slow down
to reveal themselves it's what
Michael Hague calls the getting naked
which in a romantic comedy doesn't
necessarily mean the people are are
having sex it means that's the moment
where uh in hitch Will Smith is
revealing to the girl why he's become
the love doctor because he was not the
love doctor in college in fact he was
exactly the opposite and so this is his
reaction to that
um after uh connections comes new
directions this is where the the
discovered gold really kicks in in New
Directions your character
has become somewhat accustomed to The
Impossible or probable situation and
what has happened is new skills have
arrived not because your character sat
back and thought I want to improve
myself but because they've had to
they're forced to transform and so in
New Directions your character literally
tries to go for something has it the
discovery goal go for something that
they hadn't even thought of at the
beginning of the movie in the beginning
of the movie
is Steve Carell in 40 year old virgin is
he thinking about
having a relationship with a woman no
doesn't even it's not even on the uh on
the horizon uh in the beginning of the
movie
does uh Phil Connors want to have a
relationship pursue a relationship
without sex
with Rita
no
uh you know we at first he tries to get
her to go to bed with him but he's
unsuccessful because she's not that kind
of a girl to go to bed with a guy you
know in the first day
and so he gets to a point where
he just wants to be in her company and
spends as much time with her as he can
in her company
because
he he's fallen in love with her and and
he can't figure out a way to get out of
the time Loop so he just becomes
the best boyfriend in the world
uh somebody who's not grasping for
something not not having some ulterior
motive just there for other people
Danny rubin's a Buddhist so is Harold
Ramis for that fact and so uh the
Buddhist philosophy infuses
um uh the groundhog day because the
whole point is they answered the
question how can you be a good person in
the world and the answer is to be of
service to other people
so then you have the Lost night of the
Soul uh The Dark Knight of the soul in
which the All Is Lost sequence now in a
romantic comedy this is often when the
lovers break apart
which happens you know kind of
two-thirds or three quarters of the way
through but even in a film as ridiculous
and as offensive as Tropic Thunder
um there's a breakup they the the
platoon literally breaks up from Ben
Stiller and the rest of the actors in
The make-believe platoon and that
happens about 50 of the way through the
movie so all these all these Stations of
the Cross occur they just don't occur
all at the same place all at the same
time and the and those and the the
progression can alter based upon the
need of the story
the last section is uh race to the
Finish again in many romantic comedies
you have a character literally racing to
to his loved one in When Harry Met Sally
Bill Billy Crystal is racing through the
streets to get to the New Year's Eve
party to express however ineptly his
love to Meg Ryan
but
even in enough said
uh your character needs to take some
positive action I've read several
scripts where at the end the good thing
happens to the character happens that
protagonists protagonist does nothing to
accomplish that that's probably a
mistake that's I know that's a mistake
because because your character has to
take positive action to to uh accomplish
what they need to accomplish to get what
they need to get
um and to resolve not just the narrative
but also the theme and enough said
she's broken up Julie Louis Dreyfus has
broken up with James Gandolfini
and it's broken her heart
she broke up with him because the
deception that her new best friend was
his ex-wife and she was nagging about
nagging about him about his weight
because that's what his wife was filling
Julia Louis dreyfus's head with during
their massage therapy sessions
so he breaks up with her for deception
so every now and then she drives past
his house and just parks
just looks out the window
that's all she does just drive and park
and one day he comes out he sits on the
on the stoop
and she looks at him and he looks at her
and he kind of goes
so the the important elements of Race To
The Finish
you don't have to show us a happy ending
but you have to
you have to hint at the promise of a
better world
you don't have to have the lovers come
together but we we have to know that
it's going to be okay
um in the breakup which is this
kind of revolutionary unsuccessful
rom-com with Vince Vaughn and
um
oh she's the girl from Friends
Courtney Cox no the other one oh uh
Kudrow Lisa Kudrow no the other one uh
Jennifer Aniston yeah tell her what you
want in in the breakup which is this
kind of revolutionary unsuccessful
comedy with Vince Vaughn and Jennifer
Aniston they they have this big fight
they break up there's all this deception
happening
um and then Vince Vaughn does the speech
you know the speech it's the speech that
melts the heart
of of the magical object desire it's the
speech that makes the person go you had
me at hello
uh and but what was interesting about
interesting but unsuccessful about the
film is that
he does the speech everybody in the
audience is prepared for her to go oh
it's fun and she goes no not having it
too late
oh my God they've really broken up the
film's called The Breakup we should have
figured that out so they they had a a
final scene in which they meet at a at a
like a a fair somewhere in Chicago and
Vince Vaughn has a new date that looks
exactly like Jennifer Aniston and
Jennifer Aniston has a new date that
looks exactly like Vince Vaughn and
there's this uncomfortable dialogue and
then they part and it tested terribly
because even though it was a cute joke
it left us feeling horrible about
spending two hours in this unsucci I
mean we've had our own breakups we don't
want to have to live through it again
so did they get the pill the the couple
together no
all they did
using the same exact dialogue
was they kind of meet each other on a
street
in Chicago and one of them's holding a
bag of groceries
and they have the same exact dialogue
they didn't change a word only this time
it was
you got you felt that they were okay
they had had this relationship
it broke up
they're okay and they might not be
friends but
they're okay
and it was much much better ending to
the film because you need to give us the
pro if not the happy ending you don't
need to give us a happy ending it could
be an indie film
but you need to give us the promise of a
better world
um
the other important thing about race to
the Finish is that you're not finished
when the lovers kiss that's not the end
of the film that's not the end of the
story you need to
finish the theme you need to complete
the theme what's the question you were
asking well what's the answer
we have to make the theme complete
before the film is complete before the
narrative is complete as opposed to just
ending the story
so those those are the seven steps which
I've shoehorned I've shoehorned the 12
Steps From the hero's journey into into
shoehorn them into the common hero's
journey which by the way
oh look at there look it's economic
Heroes Journey fans